Rubio has been raising alarm over the
state of Florida's election
irregularities for quite some time and
he joins us tonight on set senator
thanks very much for coming for having
me so I know your senator represents the
state of Florida and you're Pro Florida
but as objectively as you can what is
the core problem with elections in
Florida as well actually there isn't a
may 65 of 67 counties did it right you
know miami-dade County is right on the
border of Broward 60% voted for
Democrats in the Senate race and the
governor's race they got all their votes
in on time and then they did their
recount on time it is largely focused on
two counties and one particular Broward
County where you have an inept and
incompetent elections director who's
done this in the past yes so when
someone you know a perfect example is
these provisional ballots right it's
people that show up and vote you don't
show up in the system they let you vote
but they put your vote in an envelope
and then they make sure they verify you
she decided to take 205 of them and
count them on her own without submitting
him the right way to this provisional
but to the canvassing board when that
was discovered she said all right I'll
give it to the canvassing board but she
had already separated the ballots from
the envelopes they found 20 of them to
be invalid but then there's no way to
match the ballots to the envelope when
you separate him so then she submitted
205 votes to the state out of that batch
20 of them at least 20 of them are
invalid votes now she claims that
they're not part of the count which
contradicts what her lawyer said a few
days ago so when someone that
incompetent is sitting on thousands of
ballots we don't know how many they are
she's not regularly reporting them of
course we're gonna be concerned about
that and of course we're gonna be
concerned about that the reporting and
the second state of play is it's now
lawyer time lawyers are arguing to the
state that to the judge to try to get a
federal judge to do two things one throw
out state law when it comes to voter
intent they're gonna do a manual recount
in the Senate race of all the ballots
they either didn't vote in the Senate
race or double voted and there's a very
specific law for what voter antennas you
know if you circle Rick Scott or Bill
Nelson that's fine but you have to have
done it throughout the ballot right she
won't read it they want to throw out
that standard and just let it be I don't
know what can you change the standard
after the vote is that to my concern I
mean look if you say there's a problem
with the laws what the legislature is
there for but to have a judge come in
announced that Florida law after the
election we're gonna change the rules in
hopes of influencing the outcome that to
me is stealing the election and then
they also want to force them to count
every mail ballot even the ones in which
the signature didn't match the signature
on file for the voter these are the two
fundamental arguments is that the
requirement that the signature has to
yeah that's the existing requirement how
can they argue it's no longer the
require because they're saying it's an
arbitrary standard and who's making the
decision that was a standard on Election
Day right correct and I think that's
what I'm hoping a reasonable judge no
matter how activist that might be would
argue that's a good point you should
have raised it before the election and
that's something for the legislature to
fix but we're not gonna change the rules
of the election after the election to
influence the outcome because if you do
it it's stealing an election amazing so
I want to ask you about the question of
nationalism the president described
himself as a nationalist recently he was
attacked by the leader of France for
doing that you recently published also
Journal op-ed defending the idea of
nationalism yeah why is nationalism and
necessary concept in modern America well
American nationalism of course what is
our identity our identity is not a
common race ethnicity right in fact
America is a de facto rejection of that
it is fundamentally premise on this
notion we are all children of God we are
born with God we're all created equal by
our Creator and we are given equal
rights to life liberty and to pursue
happiness that is our national identity
it is deeply rooted in morals and in
values it in fact explains everything
this nation has done internationally and
domestically we should be proud of that
identity we should defend that national
identity number two I think most of the
viewers watching this program would be
shocked to think that my job is to
represent Belgium or my job is to
represent I don't have nothing I have
nothing against Belgium I always pick on
Belgium or Luxembourg
they have their own system of government
that doesn't mean I need to be hostile
towards them right and it may be in our
national interest to work with them I
think NATO was in our national interest
and is I think a lot of our alliances
are built on that and in fact our
national our national our national
identity is a nation that believes in
equality of all people is what has
caused us to defend democracy and feed
right people all over the world we
should be proud of that but as a
government leader
my fundamental obligation first and
foremost is to work on behalf of the
American people and most of the time if
not all the time we can do that without
hurting other people around the world
it's hard to know what the argument
against what you just said might be why
would object
no I sincerely because it's important to
understand what what the objections are
what do you think they could be well
there are two one is they ascribe to
nationalism sort of the nationalism of
the Nazis or somebody else that's ethnic
and racial nationalism I'm not talking
about ethnic national or snow I'm
talking about a national identity that
actually is completely relevant to your
ethnicity if I give you not to be born
here you come here legally you can be a
US citizen it's one of the great things
about America some of the people who
love America are the most are the people
who are Americans by choice yes they
know what life is like in another
country then there's another school of
thought that know we are citizens of the
international community and we have
obligations to the rest of the world
which I would agree within the confines
of our national interest in fact I've
always argued that the best thing for
the world as a strong and prosperous
America because our values infuse our
decision-making and and so much of what
we do so there are people that actually
I think that's what McCrone was arguing
and that is that Frances obligations
under him anyways are not just for the
French people but the sort of amorphous
international community which I'm not
against I've defended international
organizations so long as they are in the
national interest of the United States
because that's the country you represent
yeah I mean I swore an allegiance to the
oath I swore an oath to the Constitution
of the United States I work for the
American people and I believe I can do
so while still being strong allies of
Japan strong allies of Great Britain
strong allies of our countries around
all these countries around the world
especially when our interests intersect
I think this is a vital conversation I'm
glad that we're having it and I'm glad
here thank you articulating it so
clearly thank you senator thank you for
having